i'm filming this on my birthday all
these questions are so good i wasn't
sure about whether or not i was going to
do this as just a short video for 20
minutes or a full podcast episode but i
was going through the questions and they
were all mint
am i right i'm going to have to do them
all suit with the wide pinstripes from
like the early 90s
break dancing in a stairwell sleeveless
t-shirt [ __ ] like if you wanted
to create a human that looked like what
people think
politicians look like it would be brian
rose if there's like
anything anything at all that i hope the
people that listen to this show take
away it's that embracing your weirdness
will
improve your entire life
what's happening beautiful people
welcome back it is a 100 000 subscriber
q a special with
yours truly and no guest this will be my
first full
solo podcast episode so i hope that you
enjoy it thank you to everyone who's
tuned in
over the last three years and supported
us and shared the episodes
i really do appreciate it i asked on my
twitter and my instagram for some
questions so
that's what we're gonna go through today
let's get into it
does it annoy you that people think your
name is chris wills
yes it does uh it is very hard to get a
hold of chris williamson
on any handle on social media and
there's one guy
like some designer somewhere that bought
every url
in existence with every different
permatex chris williamson.io
chriswilliamson.au yeah so
i would like to be able to find a better
handle if possible but
not a thing what was the biggest mistake
you made on your youtube journey
that's an interesting one it's different
coming at youtube from a podcasters
perspective
because i'm only bothered about having
good conversations i've never really
learned about gaming the algorithm or
creating content that's youtube friendly
so i suppose that i should have learned
earlier
how youtube works what makes a thumbnail
clickable and a titable
a title enticing i wasn't really too
sure
um yeah i think learning the basics of
youtube
to maximize the impact you can get from
a podcast
what do you think is the biggest
misconception about you and your channel
conversely what one thing do you wish
people knew about you and your channel
yeah that is a really good question um i
think
there's two broad groups of people that
arrive at the channel one of them
are people that have seen me talk with
the big name guests that tend to bang on
youtube you
douglas murray's andrew doyle sargon of
akkad michael malus etc
and then the other side of that are
people who perhaps
know me from what i did in my past life
as a sort of club promoter and reality
tv guy
i think the biggest misconception is
probably that i'm really interested in
politics
and i love woke bashing to be honest i'm
far more interested
in individuals than i am in collective
groups i i don't
have a massive interest in politics i
don't really care about how different
groups get on and group disparities and
stuff like that
but youtube really really rewards those
sorts of episodes so they get a
disproportionate amount of attention
because they feed the algorithm so it
looks like i'm constantly talking about
politics
but if you actually take a broad view of
the 300 episodes i've done
it's like less than 10 percent of them
even
related to politics it just happens to
be those ones that get the most views
what one thing do you wish people knew
about me and my channel
it's that as i move forward i really
really want to help people
get from where i was about five years
ago which is someone who didn't really
understand himself
was not really living a
true sort of alignment of the type of
person you wanted to be
and get them to where i am now which is
feeling a lot more happy in myself i
find joy
in the things that i do i have a project
that i love and i care about
um i'm a much better friend i'm a much
better son i'm just
all around have improved myself in ways
that i thought you couldn't i've
deconstructed source code in me
that i i didn't think that you were able
to rewrite um and i really really want
over the next few months and years with
this channel to
increasingly focus on that i want to
make
down the pipe monologue youtube videos
like this that are
helping people do that that's yeah and
even thinking about that even thinking
in that sort of a selfless way
is something that i wouldn't have
considered five years ago so even that
itself
counts for um quite a lot of the
progress that i've made
where do people recognize you from the
most hosting the podcast or being on
love island
uh-huh i suppose it depends on who it is
um
i haven't been out of the house an awful
lot over last year same as everyone
we've been locked down
um i imagine that it's going to be more
from the podcast when we get re-released
into the real world
there was a period where i was barred
from the front door of my own event by
my business partner
because the love island thing because
everyone wanted to ask about like what
did you think about that girl there or
did this really happen
uh but no that's no longer uh
holding as much water i think man like
people's fame from love island is so
fleeting anyway
uh and also i would much sooner
a hundred times more prefer someone to
come up to me
and say man i love the show i really
enjoy that as opposed to what
i was watching itv2 at the time when you
came on
and did that thing in those shorts like
i
i don't need to go into that which story
from a guest do you think about the most
and how often that is an awesome
question
i think aubry marcus really opened up on
an episode i did with him which is like
nearly two years ago now
and um he used this analogy
around uh you do not serve other people
from
your cup you serve them from the saucer
which overflows around your cup
it's the same episode where he said the
persona is incapable of receiving love
it can only receive praise and um
this really resonated with me this was
sort of still as we all are right we're
still trying to grow
but um yeah this is a period where i was
like really really keen
on just trying my hardest to understand
myself and why i didn't feel fulfilled
and
how i could feel more fulfilled and find
more meaning
and uh yeah that that was awesome from
him and
i must think about it i mean it's the
basis of one of the sections of my ted
talk
so it tells you all you need to know
about how often it comes up in my mind
who are the dream guests you have yet to
interview this sort of constantly
changes based on the
uh tide of whatever my topical interests
are
at the moment a couple of years ago i'd
have said you know it would have been
jordan peterson and then a seth godin
i've had seth on the show to be an aubry
marcus aubry's been on the show
i think jordan would still be really
good um
i would enjoy to get thomas solo on i'm
only just starting to get exposed to
some of his work but he seems like an
absolute boss and he's
90 and still sharp as hell nick bostrom
from the future of humanities institute
in oxford i'm in like his assistance
assistant's email
like desperately slowly climbing my way
up the ladder trying to get my way
toward nick
he would just be awesome talking about
existential risk and stuff like that
toby ord
as well talking about x-risk and then
some top-level athletes like matt fraser
would be pretty fun
um i'd quite like to get tired to me on
as well i think she's
she's interesting um goggins
would be awesome i really do like his
mindset jocko as well
uh but these people aren't i don't think
they're out of reach like
if the show continues to do what it does
there's no reason that
they shouldn't be coming to me when
they've got a new book out so hopefully
that'll be the case
what's your biggest lesson from hitting
100k
the biggest impact on your growth online
is consistency
um i like to think that the show
gives the audience a really good sort of
broad spectrum of guests there's a big
gap in the youtube market now with rogan
only being on spotify
for people that want to listen to stuff
about philosophy or psychology and then
like about sex robots and whatever else
you know
that real broad pick and mix
of topics um and
i think that being consistent
and often knocking out episodes
week after week after week it's so rare
i think it's like
some ridiculous percentage 90 of
podcasts don't make it past
episode five and then of the remaining
of that people that do survive another
90 don't make it past episode 20
or something like that so just
consistency
like that is the way that you get better
at anything i'm now
whatever like a thousand hours deep of
talking
into cameras and microphones and um
yeah it rewards it you get better at the
things that you do so you just do it
consistently
how many followers were you on after
three six and 12 months it was like
none i don't think for the first three
months of the channel had actually
posted anything
and then um we did a what it was really
like to live on love island episode and
that kind of
at least brought the channel up to a bit
of
notoriety it goes over a thousand subs
within one video which was quite good
but man we did
we were under 5000 subs by the time i
spoke to
uh dr david sinclair and the podcast had
been going over a year
so not a lot the growth is very very
slow and the curve
return is super exponential so again
like it's that jack butcher graph right
where it's this is stupid
just as you're doing something and
continuing to do it you're just about at
that point of
all of the latent leverage kicking in so
yeah again
same as the biggest lesson like just
keep going thoughts on brian rose
running for mayor and thoughts on him in
general
snake merchant honor right okay anyone
that knows me
knows that i've had strong opinions on
brian rose since long before the
freedom fund or the brian for mayor
thing whatever his new trend of the week
is um
i've had my concerns around brian i
actually know some of the guys
who are affiliated with working for him
i won't go
any deeper than that and
his internal staff think things about
him
critically that he's a closet psychopath
that he's got bd cod eyes
um they think those things as well and
it makes me
so uncomfortable because there are
certain things he's done he's got this
video out there which is like my
relationship with alcohol
and i watched it and it's just him
monologuing down the video talking about
how he drank every day for 20 years
and now he's turned himself around and
i'm like
man not only would i not dislike you
if this was what all of your content was
like i would be an active fan
but he just tumbles into that like dan
pena shite suit with the wide pinstripes
from like the early 90s
break dancing in a stairwell sleeveless
t-shirt [ __ ] like
it it's just so off-putting it smacks
massively of someone that's a charlatan
like if you wanted to create a human
that looked like what people think
politicians look like it would be brian
rose
i really really hope that something
occurs
where he sees what he could do with a
platform of his size and some of the
conversations and guests that he has
access to
i really really hope that he just gets
back to doing his thing because
the uk even though he's adopted the uk
needs more good podcasters and it's a
shame that his huge channel
is being wasted on him walking up and
down outside of his office talking about
how the mayor of london's
like an idiot i'm bored by that stuff
now
how did you manage to get so many
excellent guests on such a relatively
small channel this is a question i get
quite consistently
obviously a lot of people want to start
podcasts and guest
quality is an indicator of the show's
uh level of respectability um really i
got lucky because a friend
lucy from reebok got me dave castro and
dan bailey as like the first two
guests after a mate for me so episode
two in episode three
the director of the cross crossfit games
and then crossfit games og
um after that i just reached out to
people i i just sent them
a very short email that respected their
time
saying what i wanted to do what i wanted
to talk to them about and why i thought
they should do it
you'd be very surprised at how
responsive people are
when you get to your top top top level
like s tier podcast guests your seth
godins your jordan petersons your
goggins
sam harris and such they're going to be
really really hard but
even them like if you have sufficient
reach
you're going to be able to get them and
then cascading all the way down you can
do the same with guests that are below
that
so yeah just reach out consistently um
don't be scared to dm people like i just
fire out dm's if i see someone that's
interesting i'll just dm them and ask
what their email address for podcast
invites is
and a lot of the time they'll just say
oh oh wait it's me i deal with it
what do you want to talk about so people
are responsive
what do you think chris five years from
now would advise you
this is such a judge mark question [ __ ]
sake man
um
probably focus on essentialism still um
i think i get distracted a lot
by shiny objects and taking that
essentialism red pill has been a big
improvement for me but there's still
so much trivial many uh
projects and thoughts that appear that i
don't need to concern myself with
um probably
assess your assumptions as well a lot of
the time the biggest
benefits and the biggest changes that i
make to myself are when i
try and take a first principles approach
on why do i think this thing do i still
need to be doing this thing
is there an easier way for me to achieve
this thing um
he would almost certainly say delegate
more um presuming that
this show and platform continues to grow
i will hate the fact that right now i
don't have anyone who assists me with
my emails or my podcast bookings or my
scheduling or the
advertisers and the sponsors that we
deal with on the show like it's me
and video guy dean and late night
that's all that there is so i think he
would say focus on what's essential
and get a [ __ ] assistant
thoughts on sam harris and his trump
derangement syndrome
okay so i did i did a video about this
and that was actually what crossed us
over
from like the late 90s through 100k was
that sam harris video
like i've just finished listening to sam
talking to some
awesome physicist about the nature of
time
and and the reality of whether or not
we're in a simulation and stuff like
that is
where for me sam is at his best um
i appreciate that trump was such a
trigger
that he took people that we think the
best of us
think that the best of us are sane and
had completely flipped them on their
head
i think about ryan holliday writing that
blog post about his dad
uh like wishing that his dad wouldn't
vote for trump and then like some of the
stuff that sam
said just seems so detached from that
balanced calm persona that both him and
ryan give off
so i totally get that trump can trigger
some people being honest
i don't care that much about politics i
said earlier on like i'm not that
bothered
about politics i appreciate that some
people become so patriotic
to their side that once someone has done
a thing that they disagree with politics
is so fundamental to their being that
they no longer want
to enjoy anything else that person has
to do
i take my uh
personas the people that i watch and
listen to i take them far more piecemeal
than that like i don't agree with jordan
peterson's views on religion
wholeheartedly but i'll definitely
listen to him when it comes to life
advice
and the philosophy of taking
responsibility and stuff like that
i don't need to take everything together
like i i don't know whether i'm going to
switch from determinism to compatibilism
in terms of free will
but just because i disagree with sam
harris on free will wouldn't mean that i
can't listen to him
when he talks about space or meditation
um yeah i i hope that this is the end of
the tds for sam though it definitely did
sort of
boar slash tarnish the stuff he was
putting out
do you think that gyms will re recover
to pre-pandemic levels
the uk i was really surprised when
gyms reopened the first time after
summer and i went in on the first day
that it was open
and it was we've got a very popular gym
800 plus members
huge massive place at reebok crossfit
tyneside
and i thought it was going to be swamped
and i really think that
there is a undercurrent of people that
are quite uncomfortable
about um just being out and around i
wonder if that'll change now the
vaccine's out but
i don't think that gyms are going to get
back to pre-pandemic levels
for a while yet um pts would be okay but
owning a facility i um i'd sort of
really hope that all the gym owners out
there have
have got their finances in order and uh
good luck to all of you because it's
gonna be
i think it's still gonna be a little bit
of time before we get back to that
what topic subject you want to learn
more about in 2021
all these questions are so good now i
wasn't sure about whether or not i was
going to do this is just a short video
for 20 minutes or a full podcast episode
but
i was going through the questions and
they were all mint and that right i'm
gonna have to do them all
uh what topic a subject you want to
learn about
in 2021 i'm really really enjoying the
evolutionary psychology stuff i'm
currently reading the apo understood
himself the apo understood the universe
by steve stewart williams
mint so good existential risk just has
this real
pull on me those two i think even though
i spent a lot of 2020 learning about
that if
there was a year to learn about
existential risk it was going to be the
year of the pandemic right
but um yeah those two what's your
favorite uncomfortable truth that you've
discovered recently this is someone who
knows
me and what i talk about um
[ __ ] that's such a good question
so i learned i learned about the
worst age to lose a child at in
the moral animal by robert wright that
we might think that to lose an infant
would be very heartbreaking because they
had so much life left
or we might think that um losing
a 18 year old just as they're about to
go out into the world and do things
might be the worst
but evolutionary psychology suggests
that
the psychologically worst time for a
parent to lose a child
is around about sort of 11 12 years old
for a girl 12 13 years
old for a boy because it's just as
they're about to become fertile
so the whole compulsion of your genes
is to be a grandparent optimizer
it's not necessarily just about having
kids it's about making sure that your
kids have kids
and therefore it means that the worst
time
as proposed by evolutionary biology to
lose a child
would be just before they're about to
become fertile because you've done all
the hard stuff
you've got them through the ridiculously
difficult period
of infant mortality which you know would
have killed
some ridiculous majority of children in
our evolutionary past
you've got them to the age where they're
just about to make it work
and then they're gone and i think this
is actually exemplified in
darwin's own life he had some insane
number of children like 10 children
i think maybe seven of them survived
until adulthood and the one which was
most painful
was the one that died i think 10 a girl
who died at 10 years old
so yeah i mean the uncomfortable truth
thing
is just seeing the motivations of our
source code
right like that's what we're looking at
when we observe this
full-on when we look at the sort of nuts
and bolts of how we're put together
the uncomfortable truths are seeing what
we are
rather than sort of what we presume
ourselves to be uh so yeah
i i really enjoy doing those i just i
enjoy putting them out as well i know it
triggers people like people get
uncomfortable about talking about
the ethics of sex robots or whether
um women being told that they need to
choose between a career and having a
family is actually good or bad for them
but these are interesting questions
i don't have a massive agenda other than
[ __ ] that's a really really interesting
question
i wonder what's on the other side of it
you've described yourself
as enigmatic because ever have i
that doesn't smack very well does it
you've described yourself
as enigmatic because the contrast
between what you used to do and what you
do now
with that in mind have you ever felt a
pull to be more legible to other people
do you ever feel misunderstood all of
these are so good
um yeah okay so
multi-layered might have been easier for
me to say
enigma is it makes me sound like i think
i'm some sort of rock star
yeah there is a little bit of a um a
juxtaposition i suppose right that
you have this person who comes through
club promo and and
in a very transactional sort of showy
industry and is now
trying to delve into the sense of what
does meaning mean and what is truth and
how should we
live a flourishing actualized life i do
understand that
that necessarily doesn't align for most
people it doesn't make sense
um have you ever felt a pull to be more
legible to others
yeah for a long time i compromised all
of this side that you guys see on the
show
in order to be successful in an industry
where people
they're bothered about your follow but
not the
quality of the content they're bothered
about who can party the hardest
who knows the most people who's known by
the most people
so i compromised for a very very long
time do you ever feel misunderstood
almost every day and i don't think
that's ever really going to change but i
don't think that's a bad thing
like to feel fully fully understood is
to be predictable
by others around you and i don't
actively go out of my way to be
unpredictable
but i think that a level of
misunderstanding
a level of being misunderstood is an
inevitable part of being a complex human
and that's actually something to be
proud of you know the fact that people
can't predict
necessarily what your interests are or
what your background is or what you're
going to do next
um that's one of the reasons that we're
attracted to people
right like we like people who have
layers
who aren't just immediately
we see them we spend a couple of days
with them we know everything that there
is to know about them
you want to be in a relationship with
someone who 50 years later you're still
discovering interesting things and
insights that they have around
themselves
so yeah i mean it's not a like dating
optimization strategy
but yeah i am i think people should be
proud
people should be proud of their uh
illegibility
to others sometimes what one thing had
the biggest impact on reaching 100k
uh it was using clips to be honest i
know that some people
sort of get a little bit annoyed that
the channel uploads clips from episodes
that they may have already seen
but the fact of the matter is there's
far fewer people that are on
youtube than have watched the episodes
and a lot of the time it's hard to get
people to commit
you know if i've got an hour and 20
minute conversation with michael mallis
it's pretty tough to get people to just
because they like michael
watch or maybe they don't even know who
he is well
dedicated 100 minutes of their time
to 80 minutes of their time to the show
so by giving them a little bite-sized
feeder of you know a seven-minute clip
or a 10-minute clip
a lot of the time that actually drags
people in and it really really works
well
on the youtube algorithms so anyone
that's a burgeoning podcast that's
listening just use clips
from your channel take the best bits of
the episodes with good name guests
and get them out there and that made a
huge impact
were you surprised by what youtube said
your listeners listened to
okay so this is a new feature in youtube
studio
that shows other channels that people
that listen to your channel watch
and mine was i'm sure dean will be able
to make it appear
here somewhere around here and um yeah
mine was
to do with everything that you would
expect literally every single person you
would expect
tim cast irl tim cast stephen crowder
ben shapiro jordan peterson
ruben report crowder uh sargon
kyle's new podcast channel the hill and
the quartering i don't know what that is
lex friedman jimmy dore
brett weinstein and brett weinstein's
clips channel and then trigonometry
so like not really it doesn't surprise
me um
there is a part of me that wishes
channels that i watch
more were on there so stuff like the
school of life
um and like sam harris's stuff and
charisma on command
things that are more about the
individuals but
those channels are huge all those ones
that i've just listed there
are over 200k or a mill
so obviously there's going to be they're
going to chew up an awful lot of the
people that watch this show
and i suppose that because of the
episodes that have banged so far
uh they do tend to be about politics um
yeah that was fairly inevitable but
i think that's going to change over the
next
year or so i'd be very interested to
come back and see what that's like in a
year's time
what type of investments do you have uh
so right now i've got nothing in the
market which i know might be
a little bit dumb but um i've also got
nothing in crypto
i have four houses i have mine and then
i have uh three other buy to let's
and they're done on an interest-only
mortgage about 25
uh ltv or 75 loan to value
um and they just tick over that's
i know that some people think that
property isn't the way to go but for me
it's been fantastic
i enjoy the process of sourcing them
and purchasing them and they generate
money in a way that i don't think many
other investments can
your capital gain is going to continue
to increase presuming that we don't have
some
catastrophe to do with the housing
market and it also generates money on a
monthly basis
so to me there's still like great money
to be made in houses
how to critique your own podcasting
skills and
learn to ask better questions
yeah um leading with curiosity
is a big part of this so just actually
thinking what do i want to know
what's that person just said and what do
i want to know this is just a general
skill for
conversations in life and i have to say
doing this show
has meant my conversational skills
have gone so improved so much more than
they ever have to
then almost in like 28 years of life up
to beginning the podcast
versus the last three years of doing the
podcast i've got better at conversations
in the last three than all 28 before
um you're just thinking like what do i
want to know from this person
they've just said a thing about this is
there something that needs clarifying
is there something that i want to dig
deeper into am i kind of done with this
topic and should i move on
the way that i think about um
structuring the podcast actually a lot
of people ask about whether or not i
script questions and stuff
i tend to write out like a rough idea of
what might be interesting to talk about
with the guest but being honest you have
no idea what their
mindset's going to be like whether they
come in and they want to talk about what
you want to talk about something
different
and never send the questions to the
guest because i like their responses and
the reactions to be natural
but yeah you just
having that having that framework of
like here's some things in case you get
stuck
or in case you're not sure or in case
you want to have a next step to move
them onto
that's like the tactic perhaps that you
would give a team to go out onto the
field of play with
but the actual game plan of what you do
when you're on the field is always
changing
and the game the tactic that you've
taken in could be thrown out the window
after two minutes so
yeah that's very much the the way to do
it follow lead with your own curiosity
allow the guests to kind of speak
and also don't be don't be worried about
sitting with silence
that was something a huge problem i had
when i began i presumed that
quiet silent moments meant that
it was boring or i had nothing to say or
maybe the guest didn't like me or
maybe the audience thought that there
was nothing going on and they'd get
bored
but a lot of the time you actually need
silence
to allow the topic to sit because
it's not just a bulleted list
of you communicating indexed information
to the
audience it's a experience that they're
going through they need time to think
about what it is that the guests or you
have just said
previously and also they're
in it for the tone and the tenor and the
cadence
of this the conversation so daniel
schmacktenberger
paused for 30 seconds to answer a
question but i didn't cut that out i
just left that in because it's like okay
well
if he thinks it's worth a 30 second
pause
then you can come along for the ride and
if that's not your bag then
there are much more highly edited
podcasts out there they're not the ones
that i listen to
but you can go and listen to the ones
that are super cut into basically just a
list of bullet points
horses for courses uh what's next what's
next
why did you start the podcast i wanted
to have more conversations
i went on the propane fitness podcast
and really enjoyed it
and i wanted to do more of them and i
guess that the easiest way to do more of
them
was for me to start my own and then i
could do as much as i wanted and
here we are why are so many young adults
obsessed with social justice
um so i'm i employ about 500
young adults right between the age of 18
and 21 that worked for my events company
and very few of them are obsessed with
social justice
and i've said this before i think it's i
wonder if it's a quirk of
being in the northeast of the uk but i
don't see
this world of gender-neutral bathrooms
and
and patriarchy oppression and stuff like
that
i don't know if it's limited in the uk
if it's limited where i am if it's
purely an american thing
i don't know um the reason that i think
that they're obsessed with it
is because there are
far fewer of the traditional routes to
success and finding meaning in life
available now than there would have been
in our parents generation
we have an abundance of luxury and
in that time we find our own wars to
fight
like in the time of a real crisis we
refocus our priorities
in the absence of a real crisis we
create our own
so that is
one thesis that might explain a
very terrible effect that's going on at
the moment did you ever
consider joining the military yes i did
actually i remember i thought it would
be really cool
to join the military because i've always
wondered what it would be like
to kind of cast off all of the
all of the considerations that you do on
a daily basis
i find making decisions choosing just
what to do with things this was like
when i was at uni
i remember thinking like if i went to if
i went in the military i wouldn't have
to i wouldn't have to think about
whether i was supposed to do something
or not i just get told to do it
wouldn't it be interesting to see what
my potential would be like if i got out
of my own way
just because i outsourced the decision
making to some higher power
and that was a brief
but i was thinking sort of semi
seriously about it my mom wouldn't have
been too happy she didn't want me to
go in the military but um yeah
that would have been something that i
would have been really interested to do
i i don't know how i feel about
conscription i really do think that
a unifying experience for all young
men maybe women as well i don't know
whether women were conscripted uh
i definitely think that it would be
interesting to have that shared bond you
know even maybe just six months
something like that
i think it could probably do a lot of
good what lessons have you learned
rehabbing from injury
that you've applied to other areas of
your life
so i'm i've been plagued with injuries
for the last couple of years which is
why i'm getting
like smaller fatter and more unfit at
the same time
but yeah rupturing an achilles taught me
that
you're far stronger than you realize so
you don't often
know that you've got this power inside
of you that allows you to deal with
things that are going to be much much
worse than you've ever dealt with before
um rehabbing my back taught me the power
of perseverance
that you need to just do things over and
over again and that embracing the grind
is an important part of the
important part of making progress that
it's it's just going to be
suck day after day for a very very long
time
and it's helped me to
[Music]
manage my motivation it certainly made
me a lot more resilient
at things like when stuff gets tough
with the podcast or
workloads with other things the ted talk
like trying to learn
a 18 minute talk wrote is
it's just the same sentences the same
words
the same inflections over and over and
over again and um
that was that's difficult but
i know that perseverance is important i
know that you need to just embrace the
work and go and do it
i know that you're going to be able to
deal with whatever the challenges are
that
end up coming up um and also learning in
some form or another to enjoy the
process like to make things that you
have to do a little bit easier
like i can't get around the fact that i
need to do
stupid girls big three and a ton of
achilles rehab every morning
so i choose to listen to a podcast while
i'm doing it and it makes that process
easier
the same way as when it's edit day for
the podcast and i need to put three
episodes up in one day and write your
show notes and do the intros and edit it
and
send the edits for the video to dean and
then make sure that the thumbnails are
all written out for the
design so that dean gets those right as
well like i just do that but i
intersperse it with listening to music
that i enjoy
or i just do other stuff that makes me
feel good throughout the day
so yeah you can turn suck into enjoyment
pretty easily
you just need to make some tweaks best
advice for a burgeoning content creator
ah just keep going like just keep on
going
in the beginning quantity is far more
important than quality
because the quality will come off the
back of the quantity that you produce
it takes so long to get good at doing
anything
and demotivation arrives
really quickly which means that if you
continue to keep going if you can
get through that demotivation you are
selecting
for a very very small sliver of other
people that are trying to do that thing
because most of them got demotivated and
stopped so if you get demotivated and
keep going
you will start to get reinforced so
there's been periods with the show like
we made we must have made like
less than a tenner in our first year
on youtube i think with like all of the
adsense money like
10 quid but i wasn't doing it for that
and then
over time when we ran out of energy
again i would
lean on dean and he'd give me support
and then i'd
like get a cool message off a
person that listens to the show and says
it really really helped them or improved
their life i'm like right
that's amazing continue to sort of just
tick over tick over with that the
periods of demotivation
know that they're gonna come keep
consistent stay on the cadence and then
now it doesn't feel like a job i don't
get demotivated with the show anymore
because i've sunk into a routine and a
rhythm of work
that if i wasn't to have three or four
episodes a week
that i need to record it would feel like
there was something missing
from life so yeah just keep going
what's your go-to tactic when feeling
unmotivated
the similar sort of question i guess um
i i do get periods of demotivation like
that are different to being outside of
work they're
more existential i suppose uh just
doing the things i have a list of things
that i know that are good for me
and that make me feel good so go outside
have a big glass of water have a walk uh
have a cold shower
uh have a good night's sleep like if you
do those things
more often than not you'll fix the
demotivation
i think the demotivation often comes
just from some sort of
physique physical challenge perhaps the
either that's dusty as [ __ ]
top of my uh top of my mic things just
to yourself uh
yeah the uh the demotivation occurs it's
a trigger because of something that
often happens physically
but then it manifests mentally and then
you start to ruminate about it
and then you think oh this is because
i'm x y and zed when it could just be
you're under slept or you haven't been
outside for a couple of days
or you're dehydrated like just focus on
the basics make sure that you eat sleep
move and drink right
and most of the other stuff ends up
being all right
what's a belief that you hold which many
people
disagree what's a belief that you hold
with which many people disagree
so this is peter thiel's interview
question
um so the main one
the one that i always give when people
ask this question is that
we need to have a new perspective on the
way that society views pedophilia
and i have to say that very very
carefully because people are too quick
to jump to conclusions about it
i think that we need to
help people and treat them from a place
of empathy
who are suffering with an awful
affliction to their sexuality
um they're completely ostracized by
society
they're hated by pretty much everyone um
and the difference between pedophilia
and child molestation
is everything pedophilia is some poor
person
who has been like basically cursed with
this
awful immoral type of sexual attraction
child molesters are people to act on it
um and
i just think that yeah the vast majority
of discourse around this is so unsubtle
and so unnuanced
and like to an extent rightly so because
it is really terrible you know children
who have been abused
they grow up with all manner of ptsd and
it's awful like you know it makes
everybody feel very very uncomfortable
but i think that we need to treat
people who are trying to recover who are
trying to
do their best to control something that
they know is malignant
uh we need to treat them with compassion
um so yeah there we go
more people annoyed uh how have the
conversations you've had on the podcast
changed you like
it's it's been one of the biggest
transformative experiences that i've
been through
ever um
i suppose that kind of speaks to the
fact that
if you do anything enough it will become
a part of you james clear talks about
this in atomic habits where he says
if you kick a football one so you're a
footballer well probably not if you do
100 kps are you a footballer well
probably not
well if you play football every sunday
for a team are you a footballer and you
go well yeah you probably are
so at what point do you become the thing
and it's when it becomes a part of your
identity
and um yeah very much
very much i see my role now
like the i see the person that i am as
someone who's different
uh fundamentally different to the person
who i was when i began the show
um i've had the fortune of speaking to
all of these like wonderful interesting
people like ryan holliday and seth
gordon and james clear and
chelsea ferguson um and
that is a very privileged position to be
in
which means that i almost uh being able
to repackage that and help other people
with those bits of advice
it's like really it's just it's awesome
like
you can't buy the insights that i've got
from the show there is no course on the
planet
that you could purchase there is no
coaching platform on earth
that would permit you the amount of
exposure that you can get
by doing something like a podcast and
yeah it's um
it's made me more mindful it's made me
more aware of my own flaws but it also
helped me to get past them
it's made me accept the person that i am
and also embrace it
help me find a voice as well like i
didn't really know
who i was massively
um because you're not forced to
articulate who you are much a lot of the
time when you're having a conversation
it's kind of fleeting
like even the longest conversations that
you tend to have with mates are like
what
20 minutes half an hour long some of the
ones that we've done on the show have
been over two hours
constantly assessing your own
motivations why do i think that thing
what is it what is my belief around this
and because it's so
cross-genre because it's across
everything from you know sport and
fitness to philosophy to
meditation to meaning to sex work to
whatever
relationships you there's nowhere to
hide
there's nowhere for your assumptions to
hide within that so yeah i think that
everybody that's listening
should try if they can to have a deep
conversation with a friend
once per week for at least an hour where
they don't use their phones during it
and
it will feel like you've done a mental
floss it feels like
it feels like rigorous therapy for
everything that's a part of your life
and the more that you do it the better
you'll get the more rigorous you'll be
with your speech the more precise you'll
be with the way that you articulate
things
it's like such a hack and everyone can
do it
you know ring your mum ring a friend
you know you probably can't see them at
the moment because we're all locked the
[ __ ] down in our houses
what's the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to you i mean
that's a deep question i came off a bike
i came off a moped
in bali and
it was paying 50 pence a day for a bike
in bali which is obviously my fault
pulled the brakes brakes didn't work
came off the bike hit the road
lost most of the skin on the left-hand
side of my body like just
coarse balinese tarmac and i've just
grated half of my body off onto the
floor
and i was riding with these two
australian dudes that were staying in my
hotel who had only really recently just
met
and they always did this they were
always in australia
and then nipping over to bali so they
were really sort of
agile on their bikes and i remember
thinking ahead of
i've just lost half the skin off one
side of my body i'm still in the middle
of a road
so there's traffic coming in both
directions and the bikes on the floor
and i'm
like in this tiny pair of swim shorts
and a vest the first thing that i felt
was [ __ ] like what a [ __ ] it's so
embarrassing
and the guys came over and asked oh mate
mate you're all right i was like uh yeah
yeah
yeah
i'm fine so i was more concerned about
looking like a [ __ ]
than i was uh caring for my own personal
safety
so that was that was fairly embarrassing
i suppose
i tend to i tend to be sort of fairly
all right with avoiding embarrassing
situations mostly
uh do you feel a sense of purpose and
service
in what you do you [ __ ] should and
thank you well thank you
um yeah this is interesting i suppose
this is another aubry marcus thing he
says in order to serve you have to be
fit for service
um and until you feel that you're fit
for service you kind of just see it as
a very one-way street right you're
having this conversation or you're
creating content you don't really ever
think about the impact that it has on
people
you know there are far far bigger
channels and people doing much greater
work
than the size and the scope of what
is happening in modern wisdom but i do
think that it's
a voice and a rhetoric that really
really needs to be heard
like obviously or else i wouldn't be
doing it um like
being radically sensible genuinely
caring
about the integrity of the words that
you say
speaking with virtue being mindful being
open to new ideas
like these things make for a good life
they help us to avoid the trappings
of being dogmatic about any ideology
about our assumptions
they allow us to be happier because they
they let us cast off
the things that we used to think and it
permits us to see the world the way that
it actually is
so i suppose now
that in terms of service i i hope so
i hope that it impacts people positively
um it certainly does me
in terms of sense of purpose yeah
absolutely i have done for the last year
or so
um very strongly since i decided to turn
pro
as uh steven pressfield calls it um like
i want to be the best
podcast in europe i don't see any reason
why that shouldn't be the case i know
there isn't an objective metric of that
i'm not bothered about being the most
played i'm bothered about being the best
which means
the most interesting conversations the
most insightful conversations
the best realizations like who is the
the guests that no one else has even
thought to get the conversations and the
places that no other podcaster even
thinks about going
or if they do think about going to it
that it's delivered in a more precise
way in a more rigorous way
in a more insightful way but those are
the things that i want to do
um and i the skill set that we've built
up between myself and dean over the last
few years
i really feel like now that the platform
100k obviously
now that we've got to that stage and we
have this big platform it feels like
right
finally i've got all this ammunition in
the magazine and i've finally got some
targets to shoot at
so i really hope that i really hope that
that does um
just continue to to make me feel the way
that it does it's very very
fulfilling how old are you i am 33 years
old
today i'm filming this on my birthday is
that cool
well i'm doing it i'm filming this on my
birthday i uh i thought i might as well
do something that i would enjoy so
answering these questions has been
i'm 33 years old today does chris watch
geordie shaw
um i don't even know if that's still
going
it can't be it can't be going during the
pandemic is it
i i did not watch geordie shore i was
actually on the first episode i was on a
bunch of different episodes at the house
parties and stuff but
the first ever episode of jody shore
ends up at our event at voodoo at
riverside which we ran for
forever years uh through voodoo events
our events company
um i what i've maybe seen that half
maybe seen like two episodes full
episodes ever
um most awkward interview
so out of 400
ish episodes no sorry 300 ish episodes
that we've done i think i haven't
published
maybe four so like a one percent
rate of failure i don't think that's too
bad
i'd do one failure out of 100 episodes
um don't tend to be awkward it's just
you feel bad for the guests because if
they're talking themselves in circles
it's just a bit like this is really not
going to look good for you
um i haven't thankfully i haven't had
many awkward ones i've just had ones
that i didn't think really showed the
guests in a very good light
um the most awkward interview that i've
ever seen
is the real wolf of wall street and
grant cardone
that was just compelling watching but it
was like a slow motion car
crash if you haven't seen it go watch it
once this video is done
it's like grant cardone
trying to be really quite alpha
and then jordan belfort being like
very accommodating as the host obviously
trying to get this conversation out
and i think grant cardone just sees it
as a big a big dick measuring
competition it's so
that's so bad is seeing yourself as
weird or having weirdness a lack of
self-love and acceptance
i don't really know what that means
uh i i suppose
if what you mean by this is
i think that the assumption here is that
using the term weird or having weirdness
means that you don't see yourself as
worthy of love and acceptance for me the
term weird or weirdness
is just a different iteration
of unique or one-of-a-kind that's all it
is
like people want to be unique and
spectacular and astounding in life
but for some reason because of the quirk
of weird or weirdness it's
associated because of playground
mentality with being a loner
or not being popular or not being
successful but
no i i don't think that you can find
people
who get non-typical results without them
having weirdness inside of them
and if there's like anything anything at
all that i hope the people that listen
to this show take away
it's that embracing your weirdness will
improve your entire life
what do you have planned for the
relaunch of your events business
ah that is an interesting one so bojo
came out this week and said that
this road map to recovery
which the 21st of june i think is the
day
that is being predicted for nightclubs
to come back but the only way that works
is if there's not a single speed bump
along the way which i just can't see
happening like it would be awesome if it
did but i just can't see it happening so
we will go back to probably our lockdown
lineup of events which would be um
monday tuesday at wunderbar
and then uh thursday friday at the
points
but what we want to really get back to
is the proper
lineup that we have where it would be
monday quids in a digital
uh tuesday uh prism has been sold so we
can't do that anymore
uh but then thursday at the points on
friday at top
so that is really where we want to be
but i i don't know like i think talking
about events and nightclubs still when
the r
rate and the the level of infections and
the deaths and stuff or where they're at
like what we can't really even plan for
anything
it's gonna be very very difficult but
i'm looking forward to getting stuck
back in i very much missed
being on the front door of nightclubs
what's the best advice
you ever got or gave god
um
greg mcewan talking about essentialism
saying
that to do less but better is
one of the answers to a common malady
of the 21st century i think is
is a pretty good one um especially for
me with the
type a sort of curious distracted by
shiny things
personality that i have i
genuinely think that most problems can
be fixed by people just saying no to
more stuff
and that was certainly true for me so
yeah i would say
the core thesis of essentialism to do
less but better
to focus on the vital few and not the
trivial many is
probably the most impactful advice that
i've had over the last year
what does your typical training week
look like
uh so right now given that i'm
recovering from
the achilles rupture i can't do any
functional stuff
i can't do much functional stuff i'm not
running quite yet
so for me it would be pull and push
back and chest then it would be a legs
and shoulders day
and then it would be conditioning and
arms so it's like a classic bodybuilding
split
but i guess it's just yeah
push-pull with legs and shoulders put
together and then conditioning with the
with the pumpy stuff
that to me actually ends up being a much
easier way to put your programming
together because you can train
upper back and chests together and i
find that it actually sets my shoulders
in a nicer place
especially if i warm up for chest by
doing some heavy rows first
it means that when i go to bench my
shoulders are locked in and down
and it feels a lot better whereas if
like me you've been training chest for
75 years it means that as soon as you
start working up through those sets if
you're not doing anything
to retract your scapula and bring you
back into that nice open position for
your shoulders
you wake up the next day and you just
wrecked like it really is quite
uncomfortable because obviously
posturally
all of those of us that just did chest
mondays seven days a week
for a couple of years have ended up with
some imbalances
it's really important that i open up
with that so
chest and back shoulders and legs arms
and conditioning together
uh and that'll be maybe five days a week
so monday tuesday wednesday friday
saturday
what's your outlook on life and humanity
um
[Music]
i suppose that
focusing as i said earlier on focusing
on things
which truly
truly matter and a truly true um
is going to be very very important over
the next few years there is a one in six
chance that we don't make it through the
next century
uh because of the existential risks that
we're facing
and having the smartest people of our
time
obsessing over whether boys or boys and
girls or girls
doesn't seem like a very good way for
humanity to move forward
so i hope that we get past
this sort of dogmatic collectivist
mindset
and we focus on what really matters
because there's only one cradle of
humanity at the moment and it's here
and if something goes wrong there is no
do-overs like if we
face an existential risk we're screwed
like elon's not on mars yet
we were wrecked in terms of an outlook
on life it's
changed significantly over the last few
years
and i think that
trying to find joy today in whatever it
is that you do is an important part of
that
i'd always been very much a i'll be
happy when
type person i'll be happy when i hit 100
000 subscribers i'll be happy when
i finally live in this house or buy this
car
or have this kind of life or
whatever but tomorrow that tomorrow is
never ever ever going to come
it is going to continue to roll away
from you and
the only way that you can stop the only
way that you can win that game is by
stopping playing
by saying i'm just going to find joy in
whatever it is that i do
and the easiest way to access that as
everyone knows is to try and be present
to try and
take some gratitude for whatever it is
that you're doing the food that you're
eating the
chair that you're sitting on you don't
feel it's a good example so wherever
you're sat
or stood or driving right now just
feel the sensations that are coming
through your body
so feel the chair underneath your bum or
fill the floor underneath your feet
feel the steering wheel underneath your
hands i feel the earbuds in your ear
like those sensations are at the
forefront of your experience
and yet you never notice them you never
think about them unless something
catastrophic happens and you stand on
like a piece of lego toy or an upturned
plug
those sorts of things show us that there
is far more going on
at a simplistic and basic level that we
can take notice of
that reminds us whatever is true of life
is happening right now
and over complicating things presuming
that
some level of achievement or some level
of material wealth or
some amount of success in life is going
to be the answer
is just it's a misnomer because that
success is always going to continue to
run away from you
whereas those things the way that you
feel right now the things that you can
see the taste of your food
like those things are real and they can
provide an awful lot of joy
i'm aware that it sounds very minimalist
that coming from someone who's doing
100k subscribers
celebration video to talk about like
just finding you know find find meaning
and peace
in the present moment but it is true
like you can want the success
but not make it about the success i
think that's important actually i i
finished with this example from tim
o'reilly from o'reilly media
he talks about money on a road trip and
he says that
money is like gasoline on a road trip
you need to make sure you've got enough
gas
to get you through the trip but you're
not doing a tour of gas stations either
and i think that that really highlights
where i'm at at the moment which is
i've not totally cast off all of the
the trappings and and the desires for
success
and quantifiable objective metrics of
achievement like this channel hitting
100k makes me very very satisfied
but it makes me satisfied because not
because
of the number itself but because it's a
representation
and a milestone of part of a bigger
journey that i feel compelled to do and
i feel is meaningful to me
um i don't think
everyone can or necessarily should
totally cast off their desires for
material success
having nice things is nice having
success and achieving goals is also nice
being famous and wealthy can also be
enjoyable and fun
you can enjoy the success and use the
success
but always remember that it isn't about
the success
and i think that that's where i'm at in
my less gracious moments
i still the same as everyone get drawn
into obsessing over the youtube studio
app and seeing how many plays we've done
today and oh god it's gone down like
should
maybe we should try and do this maybe it
wasn't good enough maybe this this this
and then as soon as you breathe you just
realize like
it didn't matter like just continue to
focus on the process of doing the things
of
whatever it is that you're compelled to
do whether it be making a podcast or a
youtube channel or being the best mom or
dad that you can or
being a good boss being a good worker
being a good whatever
like as long as all that you're doing is
trying to do your best
trying to focus on being present in that
moment trying to provide the things that
you can do
in the highest quality way that you can
everything else ends up falling into
place anyway i hope that you enjoyed
that
that is officially my first monologue
episode
and the 100k subscriber completed thank
you very much to everyone for tuning in
i really really really enjoy this show
and i hope that it
continues i hope that you have enjoyed
being a part of it so far
uh big love from me and video guy dean i
will see you very very soon indeed
[Music]
peace
[Music]